review you've done so many things on the
show that are terrible as yet were there
any things that you haven't gotten a
chance to do yet that your character
hasn't done well we are writers room had
like three walls wall to ceiling of
index cards with possible reviews on
them so there's so many we didn't get to
and I was just looking through a bunch
of them in a box and there are a bunch
of just weird ones that I can say now
because the series is winding down we
will never get to we will never find out
what's it like to kick Steely Dan's ass
oh we're never gonna find that out right
right you think they would have
participated that would have been great
I doubt it I'll bet you they don't
realize how much people want to kick
their ass thing they were probably
insulted another one on there was what's
it like to fart in a baby's face for god
that's not our science disgusting I'm
glad you cut that one me too we talked
about it for a little while we thought
he would get a babysitting job and then
he would be seen on the nanny cam doing
it that's as far as we got yeah but
another one another card just said Luke
Skywalker hand so I think that would
have been he would have had to find like
a like a disgraced veterinarian on the
dark web to like take off his hand so he
knew what it was like to be Luke
Skywalker to be missing a hand and have
it replaced worth robotics uh-huh
we didn't do that one I think it's a
good idea to you know what even though
it's fun to hurt forests to a certain
extent somehow that actually removing
his hand didn't seem like it was gonna
be fun right right there's one level of
humiliation you didn't want your
character to go apparently now there is
a lot of talk that your character may
this this this may be it that that the
show might end in the next episode oh
yeah
no one's saying if this is the last
episode or not I honestly don't remember
I have no idea how many episodes we made
I don't keep track of stuff like that
okay I don't have there could be 30
episodes maybe last week's episode was
the last one I don't pay attention to it
yeah well you're at the gym all the time
well there's one rumor that your
character dies in the final episode and
I think that that's been fueled somewhat
by this billboard oh you're a Los
Angeles
the final season he might die he might
die yeah some possibility right
according to that billboard that built
that's one of the most exciting things
about having a Comedy Central show is
that they give you that billboard on the
Sunset Strip I think it's just there so
that the actors in the show can go and
pose for selfies with it right whole
point of it right yeah so but you're not
gonna say right now if your character
dies I don't remember I can't for the
life of me remember how we ended the
show or how many episodes it is I simply
don't have any idea Wow why would I lie
you're really not a real person
[Laughter]
you